hi I'm Andrea Crawford with IBM cloud
we're going to talk today about DevOps
as the name implies DevOps is about
bringing together two traditionally
contentious groups within IT
organizations application development
which has primarily been measured on the
number of changes features and defects
fixed that are able to be pushed out
into production whereas IT operations
and their success is primarily measured
on system stability availability so we
have one group with pushing more changes
and another group that's saying don't
push any changes so let the fireworks
begin
DevOps transformation is an important
part to our clients transformation
strategies in general particularly
because of two main benefits one of
those being velocity velocity in terms
of how quickly products or applications
can be piped through this release
pipeline the second benefit quality it's
not enough just to be quick in terms of
how fast applications are delivered but
we also must be cognizant of the quality
of what gets delivered on the other end
of that pipeline digital reputations are
at stake here
so quality and velocity both need to be
balanced the war between application
development and IT operations really has
one big loser and that is the business
because you see the benefits are really
going to manifest themselves in terms of
business agility through being
responsive to consumer demands to
changing market conditions and basically
improving overall time to market of what
an enterprise can deliver to its
consumers if you were to think of
application delivery as a supply chain
or a pipeline we really have this notion
of ideation user stories
should be delivered in terms of adding
value to the business and its consumers
so we have ideation over here this is
also in the form of user stories work
items and the like then we have the
coding piece this is all about
programming the idea from the user story
and then we have build this piece here
includes unit test cases packaging of
the code into executables and runtimes
that will actually be then deployed on
some sort of runtime environment be a
bare-metal virtualized environment or
the cloud and then we have managed and
this is all about addressing what
happens to an application once it lands
in its runtime environment and this is
primarily focused on production but it
can also be management in terms of what
you have in dev test pre prod and the
like and then to round out the supply
chain here we've got learn and this is
all about continuous improvement so not
only do we need to understand are we
getting faster as we deliver
applications but is the quality
improving - so we want to make sure that
our benefits are being achieved
throughout the pipeline here so if we
were to identify the use cases for how
to increase velocity and quality in the
pipeline
there are really three primary use cases
the first is optimizing the core by core
systems I mean those systems that are
deep within the enterprise these tend to
be monolithic legacy big systems of
record typically these applications are
very difficult to modernize refactor and
the like DevOps for the core often looks
like retrofitting automation in situ so
that we can optimize what we've got the
second use case is about
locking the legacy so this is all about
addressing culture ways of working and
bringing development and operations
together in new ways
integrated multidisciplinary teams and
this amps up any kind of automation that
we could have done in the core and then
the last unleashing the digital so with
the maturation of cloud native apps
twelve factor kubernetes and docker were
all about continuous delivery from
ideation all the way through to
continuous improvement and rounding back
to the beginning so what we learned that
we can do better we feed it back into
the pipeline this is all about modern
applications delivered by modern teams
on modern platforms so if we were to sum
all of this up DevOps is all about
people process and tools for the benefit
of business agility thanks for watching
this video if you have any questions or
comments be sure to drop a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future be sure to LIKE and subscribe